[Music]
hello everyone today we have a beautiful
day to explore a farm full of ripe
pomegranates join me as we dive into the
process of growing and harvesting this
amazing fruit and discover the
incredible benefits it brings to our
health
[Applause]
[Music]
these vibrant red pomegranates aren't
just visually stunning They are packed
with impressive nutritional value
originating from the Mediterranean
region pomegranates have become one of
the most popular fruit crops globally
especially for producing
juice inside the pomegranate are Jewel
likee seeds called arrows each arrow is
wrapped in a thin juicy layer with a
refreshing and delicious taste and
they're packed with essential nutrients
like vitamin C and K as well as powerful
antioxidants you can enjoy the arrows
directly or press them into a
nutrient-rich juice pomegranate juice
can be sweet or slightly tart but most
fruits provide a balanced pleasing
flavor this juice has long been a
popular drink in Europe and the Middle
East and it's now widely enjoyed across
the United States and Canada drinking
pomegranate juice regularly is not just
a treat but also offers numerous health
benefits it helps fight oxidation
protects the body from free radicals
improves heart health supports digestion
and even contributes to healthier
[Music]
skin now let's take a closer look at how
pomegranate trees are grown and
nurtured pomegranates Thrive best in
loose nutrient-rich soil with a PH range
between 6.5 and 7.5 Farmers often
supplement the soil with organic compost
to enhance its nutrient content and
improve
[Music]
structure the pomegranate seedlings are
carefully selected about 3 months old
and approximately 1.2 M tall they are
then planted in prepared holes with
sufficient spacing to allow the trees to
grow
properly pomegranates are drought toall
an making drip irrigation the most
effective watering method the drip
system provides water consistently and
accurately ensuring the trees receive
adequate moisture without wasting
[Music]
water after the first year pomegranate
trees begin to flow and bear fruit
however for stable commercial production
and high quality fruits we need to wait
about 2 to 3 years after planting
[Music]
harvesting pomegranates is not a process
that can be rushed picking the fruit too
early will result in underdeveloped
flavor and quality reducing its
commercial value the first fruits of the
Season often shed naturally as part of
the tree's natural process discarding
those that don't meet the quality
standards pomegranates are typically
ready to be harvested about 120 130 days
after the fruit sets in before
harvesting Farmers carefully inspect
each fruit to ensure it has reached the
perfect ripeness with vibrant red color
a plump skin and an ideal weight of
around 400
[Music]
G now it's time to start
harvesting harvesting pomegranates
require skill and precision workers use
specialized scissors to cut each fruit
from the branch carefully handling them
to avoid damaging the skin this process
is done entirely by hand ensuring that
each pomegranate is treated with care
[Music]
after being harvested the pomegranates
are neatly packed into baskets and
transported to the processing facility
here they go through stages like
cleaning sorting and packaging to
prepare for juice production
[Music]
pomegranates are not just for juicing
they are also a fantastic ingredient in
culinary arts the vi red arrows can be
added to salads desserts and even main
dishes to enhance color and
[Music]
flavor pomegranate syrup known as
grenadine is another product made from
pomegranates and is widely used in
cocktails like tequila sunrise and
Shirley Temple
[Music]
pomegranates also carry deep cultural
significance symbolizing abundance
fertility and eternal life in many
ancient cultures so we've journeyed
through the entire process of growing
and harvesting pomegranates and explored
the wonderful benefits this fruit offers
it's a labor of love from the farmers
who tend to these trees bringing fresh
nutritious pomegranates to our tables
thank you for joining me on this journey
don't forget to like And subscribe so
you won't miss any of our upcoming
videos see you next time on our next
adventure
[Music]